movies
ok je rentre dans le système lingo in my
life tu fous là
sarah la rampe ça tu te souviens quand
tu m'as prenait hâtives alors quand on
était petit tu te souviens quand on
était petit et pour jouer à la bataille
à la casse toi
games
oui bah nan tu sais pas coudre connard
attendait zoomer l'enseigné
dieu je vous mets sur ses lunettes
qu'est ce que c'est c'était un pixel
noir monsieur c'est parce que j'ai une
résolution de mer de fait alors du coup
on va rien pathmanathan pas la chose
c'est bon trois partez sur moi je vais
frire
non wahou fait quoi mais pour que les
portes et moi quand je peux je peux
peut-être marcher non
aof
surikate